is an essential bulwark of freedom and
democracy in the Pacific
it's also a Leading Light in the network
of Liberty around the world
free Nations who fight for the values
that we believe in
you have stepped up
on trade on defense and you have spoken
out against tyranny
and as a fellow Democratic island nation
the bonds between the UK and Japan are
getting stronger and stronger we're also
working much more closely with our
freedom loving allies and I think that's
what we can see today we can see a real
collection of Nations that's come
together
this Nexus is going to be incredibly
important for the future of freedom
and that's what I want to talk about
today
after serving in the UK government for
10 years
in all kinds of roles culminating in
being our prime minister
I am convinced there is no more
important issue of our time
and I'm also convinced that the next few
years are going to be absolutely
critical for the future of freedom
it's great that today we have so many
parliamentarians from around the world
who are involved in this organization
and who want to share ipac's platform
I think it shows just how important this
agenda is
and although there are many things we
disagree with each other on we share the
same fundamental values I believe in
democracy a belief in Freedom and a
belief in self-determination
I know that we can make a great
contribution working together on a
strong response to the Strategic issues
posed by the People's Republic of China
and I want to thank all the people at
ipac who've worked so hard to make
today's Symposium happen
let's be clear
the Free World is in danger
we're living in very turbulent Economic
Times
right through from the shock of the
financial crisis through to the covert
crisis that we're still recovering from
we have less of the world's population
living under democracy than we did 30
years ago
meanwhile we have authoritarian regimes
that are building up their armaments as
well as they're building up their
arguments
and they're not just trying to convince
their own populations they're also
trying to win over global opinion
and they're trying to create a new
Global World Order
now on the subject of China which we're
talking about today
no one would rather see a free
Democratic prosperous China than me
of course I would
I'm a huge admirer of Chinese culture
and civilization
I've traveled to Beijing in Shanghai and
Chong King and Wuhan long before we saw
the pandemic emerge
in classrooms businesses and factories
I've seen the application the Ingenuity
and the hard work of the Chinese people
but these people are being ill-served by
a regime which is about control
it's not about freedom
some people say that standing up to this
regime is a hopeless task
that somehow the rise of a totalitarian
China is inevitable and we just have to
face facts
but I reject this fatalism
and the Free World has a significant
role to play
in whether or not this happens
and if it happens how it happens
after all we encourage China to embrace
economic freedom
we believed that it would mean that the
citizens of China gained political
freedom but the reality is that the
opposite has happened
Nixon became the first U.S president to
visit the people's public Republic of
China
his handshake would be known as the
handshake that changed the world
and that was no understatement
less than 30 years later China was
admitted to the World Trade Organization
and at the time people didn't pay very
much attention to this
but it catalyzed China's rise
to become one of the world's largest
economies
and it wasn't long ago
that in the United Kingdom we hailed the
Golden Era
of UK China relations
we rolled out the red carpets for the
Chinese president with all the Pomp and
ceremony that came with a state visit
I should know I attended a banquet in
his honor at the time
looking back I think this sent the wrong
message
a few years later China removed the
two-term limit on the president
and the one party State strengthened its
grip on power at home
and it also gained even more influence
on the world stage
we ignored far too many of the warning
signs from the Tiananmen Square massacre
to the so-called uighur re-education
camps not to mention the disgraceful
dismantling of one country two systems
in Hong Kong
much of the world has turned a blind eye
to these actions at least until recently
since it was the Free World that enabled
China's rise it must be the Free World
that challenges its economic dominance
before it is too late
we know that President XI has been very
clear
it's his ambition for China to have
control of Taiwan
in my view this would be disastrous
in 2022 China sent 1700 planes into
taiwan's air defense identification Zone
that's nearly double the amount that
there were in 2021
in 2023 we've already seen live fire
drills
the message needs to be heard loud and
clear in Beijing that these incursions
aren't acceptable
so-called reunification
is a core project of President xi's
Administration
and let's remind ourselves of his words
in 2021
the historical task of the complete
reunification of the motherland must be
fulfilled
and will definitely be fulfilled
Taiwan is a beacon of freedom in a world
where civil liberties and human rights
are often suppressed
it's a flourishing democracy with a
thriving Free Press
and human rights and an independent
Judiciary we should be doing all we can
to strengthen our ties with Taiwan
we know that doing more now will help
prevent tragedy later
NATO kept the peace in Western Europe
and became arguably the most successful
military Alliance in history
and we have to ask ourselves
if we'd admitted native Ukraine to Nato
would Vladimir Putin have dared to
invade
or indeed if we put stronger sanctions
in place after 2014 or supplied weapons
to Ukraine earlier would we be seeing
the amount of human suffering we're
seeing in Ukraine as well as the threat
to European and Global Security
could we have saved huge numbers of
lives
we must learn from the past and we must
ensure that Taiwan is able to defend
itself
we must work together across the Free
World to do this and that is what in my
view today is all about
I would like to see a more developed
Pacific defense Alliance
alongside even closer cooperation
between NATO and our Pacific allies
I'm delighted that Japan and the UK have
recently signed a new defense agreement
and the UK is the first European country
to sign a reciprocal access agreement
with Japan and only the Third Country
globally to do so
this will mean we can have more defense
and security cooperation that we can
undertake complex military exercises
together and we can straight from the
UK's indo-pacific security pledge
I also congratulate prime minister
kashida for Japan's historic new defense
strategy
and his championing were free and open
in day Pacific
Japan has backed this up with record
defense spending this year and also
takes up its seat of the um Security
Council
we've also seen increased action from
the G7 and the G7 is the body that has
really stepped up alongside our friends
and allies that have worked with us in
areas like sanctions in areas like
standing up for freedom and democracy
around the world
in 2021 we put out a statement on Taiwan
led by the UK in 2022 it was led by
Germany and I'm sure it'll be on the
agenda for Hiroshima later this year
under Japan's leadership
it's so important that we all do what we
can to support Taiwan because we know
that prevention is better than cure
if we build up the defense links now if
we build up the economic links now we
can help protect Taiwan and we can help
protect freedom
now of course
we need to make sure that democracies
are successful economically for the good
of our own populations it's what people
it's the Democracy can deliver and that
we have the wherewithal to provide
citizens around the world with the
opportunities that they deserve
together there's huge strength in our
economies in our economic model and it's
a model that's based on freedom it's not
based on coercion
deeper economic integration between the
Taiwanese and world economies will go a
long way to help preventing conflict
the G7 represents over 40 percent of
global nominal GDP and if we add our
friends in the European Union and I'm
looking at you give a hofstat we can get
to over half of the world's GDP now that
is a hugely powerful position to be it
and we need to use that economic power
for the good of freedom and democracy
that economic weight means that we can
influence other countries
it means that we can make decisions
about how we trade where we invest what
technology we export
we need to use that leverage to ensure
the G7 plus its allies act as an
economic NATO
this means supporting freedom and not
allowing it to be undermined
this opportunity isn't going to be there
forever
we know that China is building its
domestic Market in anticipation of
harder times ahead
but at present China is dependent on
exports to the West
now is the time to make sure that
Commerce and trade is free and not
coercive
and there are ways this can be done
we can move to an economic Article Five
where the one for all all for one
principle
is wielded in defense of our values
I believe there are three areas we
should focus on
Supply chains investment and trade
on critical minerals and Supply chains
we need to work together to make sure
we're using trustworthy suppliers
so-called friend Shoring
and that's what we've already done
in the UK
by eliminating Russian energy from our
supplies by also eliminating Huawei from
our telecoms Networks
and we need more collaboration between
free countries to make sure we're taking
similar steps
and protecting our Economic Security in
areas like chips and areas like
technology exports
and we need democracies to commit
together to audit and reduce dependency
in those critical Industries
we cannot have a situation where Beijing
has the power to turn our life
on investment we need to work together
to make sure it's not used to undermine
freedom and democracy
China's Belton Road initiative is
far-reaching and it's been used to buy
influence around the globe
last year the G7 launched the global
partnership for infrastructure and
investment an alternative that is free
from strings of trash
by stepping up this effort and I know
it's on Japan's G7 agenda we can bring
more countries into the orbit of free
economies
and isn't it amazing
that at the World Trade Organization
China is still designated as a
developing country
this means it's not held to the usual
rules on transparency is not being held
to account for its aggressive practices
this needs to change
on trade we need to work together to
make sure that trade is a force for
Freedom not a force for coercion
I'm delighted that the UK is in the
final stages of negotiating accession to
the cptpp and I really congratulate
Japan on the huge leadership
the country took on along with Canada to
make cptpp work and make it happen
because I think it's a huge Force for
good
I'd like to see this agreement expanding
to even more countries because I think
it can be a bulwark for free trade as
opposed to trade that is seeking to
undermine
based global system
we should also be seeking more bilateral
trade in the group investment agreements
with Japan we're sorry with Taiwan
and we need to make sure
that we are rushing to the defense of
Any Nation that is targeted
through unfair Trade Practices
because of the way they speak out now
during prime minister Scott Morrison's
time in office in Australia and he
referred to this earlier China imposed
tariffs on Australian wine because it
didn't like what the Australian
government was saying
and they went even further with
Lithuania
and completely blocked inputs from that
a Brazen attempt to bully a smaller
country all of this was done as
punishment beholding China to account
and standing up for Taiwan we have to
remember that our strength is in numbers
I support Japan's efforts to create a
mechanism that enables us to join forces
when one of our number is targeted
and this applies to doing business with
Taiwan
the more economies that do business with
Taiwan the more difficult China will
find it to pressurize countries that to
change tax
there are other ways that Taiwan
deserves our support
many countries have limited diplomatic
and ministerial ties to Taiwan due to
agreements negotiated with China
the world has changed since then
and some of those arrangements were
being rethought
and I believe we need to find ways to
elevate taiwan's status to reflect its
Global value
Taiwan is still excluded from many
International organizations such as the
World Health Organization
it's not just bad for Taiwan it also
damages our access to information
this lack of status was very unhelpful
during the covert pandemic
we had a lot to learn from Taiwan but
unfortunately the channels to
communicate properly simply weren't
available
righting this wrong wouldn't just be in
our interests
to help ensure that the people of Taiwan
are able to speak for themselves rather
than being spoken for
in conclusion colleagues
Confucius warned us
study the past if you would Define the
future
we need to learn the lessons of the past
if we're to ensure a safer and a Freer
future
appalling war in Ukraine serves as a
stark reminder of why we need to stand
up to the threats of authoritarian
regimes early
our response to the Russian invasion of
Ukraine has been good and effective
since the war started
just last week president zielinski
visited to the United Kingdom I have the
opportunity to meet him and he thanked
Us in the UK for what we have done to
support him and his fellow countrymen
but I regret that we in the west weren't
tougher earlier in response to
aggressive and hostile actions from
Moscow
so when it comes to China
failure to act now could cost us daily
in the long run
our governments must signal to the PRC
that military aggression towards Taiwan
would be a strategic mistake
the International Community should agree
a package of coordinated defense
economic and political measures to
support Taiwan now
we need this first and foremost to
protect the interests of the people of
Taiwan
but it's also about protecting our
interests ensuring trade for free
navigation can continue unimpeded
we need this now before it's too late
free democracies need to work together
if we are to live in a free and peaceful
world thank you
[Applause]
G7 Plus
foreign
[Applause]
it is my great pleasure to be able to
welcome
the former prime minister of the United
Kingdom
Miss distress a few other